so welcome everybody
and thank you
for
attending this session
so as you guys know that we had a pretty
um
it's a pretty cool presentation this uh
this morning on training
and so i'm gonna kind of continue on the
same theme except i want to concentrate
more on
surgical training
and
also talk about
assessment
um and then also talk about the results
we can obtain from it so addressing
animal welfare and co-founding back
factors
so within next 45 minutes to 50 minutes
we'll talk about conventional training
or also refer as traditional training
we're going to talk about refined
training so this is something that we
have brought on from
the human surgical training side to
the veterinary slash laboratory animal
side we're going to talk about
the phases that are part of the training
and we can also give you some
information regarding the studies
that we have performed addressing this
type of training
and then we're going to spend probably
about
20 minutes or so talking about
competency assessment
and also
supposed to remind you that at the end
of the session we're going to have a q a
so if you have any questions we'll i'll
be more than happy to address those at
that time
so
before we move forward um i would like
to can i get to know you guys a little
bit more
and so here's a little poll
if you could take a couple seconds to
answer that
paul please
so does this institution offer rodent
surgical training
great so slamming some folks responding
great so it's about 50 50.
so also
does your institution require surgical
training prior to performing rodent
surgery
so meaning the people
must take training before they're
actually approved to perform the certain
procedures at your facility
and again i'm going to give you you know
10 15 seconds to answer this poem
so here we see it's about 70 yes and
30 no
so you have two more questions for you
guys
so when do you perform
surgery
so 40 of you guys still and 60 percent
of you guys don't that's pretty cool
and
the last question
is do pis perform ronald surgery at the
institution
so we're not talking about the core
surgical core that does that but actual
pi's
so these answers are also gonna let me
to gauge a little bit some of the
information and how to present it to you
guys
so we're not wasting
your time
so the question for my honesty with the
pi so it's principal investigators
i apologize should i clarify that so
scientists
so it's 60 yes and 40
no
great
so
i'm going to talk about
about surgical training
just close that pole there
show it's coming up again
so we're going to talk about gastric
fiber surgeries and mice and rats when
we address these different training
phases and the reason for that is
because that's one of the most common
procedure that we have
taught within last four years or so uh
in mice as well as in rats but again
pretty much everything that we're going
to talk about today you're going to be
able to translate into other
surgical procedures as well pretty much
in surgical training in general
so
one of the things that
at most of the facilities we have by
methodology
training and then we have also surgical
training and that's how we can also
split i guess divide the procedures that
we perform we have methodologies or
biomethodologies kind of like doing ip
injections subcutaneous injections
moving animals from cage to cage
and then you have the surgical
procedures
so when we're looking on the pain scale
the methodologies the chances of them
introducing pain
or suffering are kind of on the left
hand side on the lower side when it's
compared to surgical so on surgery when
you're looking on
the right side
the chances of actually pain is
significantly higher
and when we did a non-scientific
survey where we found that 99
of institutions provided and required
methodology training meaning before you
actually were able to handle rodents you
had to learn how to move the rotor from
cage to cage how to handle it but when
we
asked about surgical training
that was significantly different so two
percent of institutions
only required
um surgical training prior to
performance surgery um and
nine percent um of them actually
provided the training and again this was
about a year ago or so but personally
since i came into the laboratory animal
field which has been a little bit over
15 years now i always find it amazing
that almost every institution
requires and provides biomethodology
training but not surgical training
and we'll talk about a little bit more
so the conventional training for surgery
here and most especially when you're
talking about scientists and pis
the way that really works is that
they'll read a paper and
they'll try to perform those procedures
and people who perform performance
procedures do not have surgical
background
you know their phd students they don't
have a veterinary background or medical
background
so they pretty much read the paper
descriptions and then try it on live
animals and i know that's changing a
little bit within last couple years or
so
so
for us the way we
refined the training is that we split it
into four phases so you have phase one
and phase two
where you have the basic and advanced
training and that's performed on
anonymous tools so not animals not
animal tools we don't use animals during
those two phases
then you have phase three where you
perform actual training utilizing the
animals and then you have phase four
where you address proficiency
and again this is something that we're
really translating from the human
surgery side to the veterinary lab
animal side and it has been validated
and demonstrated that on the human
surgery side this type of training
really does work but then the question
always comes out
is this going to work in our
in our field um and one of the other
challenges is that
on a human surgery side you have you
know six seven eight years to learn
surgical procedures
for us you know people want to learn
these procedures in a couple hours half
a day um so when we looked at can we
find a model that's similar to that it
was really challenging but when we moved
to wake forest
here in north carolina they actually do
training for the government
so for example they train navy seals
people who have no surgical background
no medical background but they'll teach
you for example how to amputate a limb
when they're actually in the field and
that training takes about two to four
weeks or so
so it's very condensed training
and it does work and they actually
utilize these various non-animal tools
before
they actually get into either using
cadavers or animals so using that model
which again has been validated we're
translating that into the lab animal
side
so one of the things that we look at
during when we introduced this step of
training was confidence so why do we
care about confidence
uh well a certain confident surgeon will
perform their procedure
faster and just more confident so the
movements are different
and give you more confidence so for
example you're not going to have these
jagged edges where you would have with
potentially someone that's not confident
and when we compare this is an n of 25
when we compared
the conventional the trading traditional
training uh to the refined training
and what we find out is that
people are significantly more confident
with that training um and again i'll
talk about a little bit more detail why
that makes that more of a difference
then we also look at the comfort level
and again this is those are two things
that are also being addressed on the
human surgery side as well
so the comfort level if a person is not
stressed they're not tense
they can relax and perform a procedure
so your muscles don't tire as quickly um
and it has an impact on the outcome of
your procedure so you don't fatigue as
fast
and again
here what we found is that with the
refined training
the comfort level is significantly
higher than with the conventional the
traditional training
so now let's talk about the phase one so
this is the basic procedures basic
training
and this phase includes things like
using a microscope
how do you handle the instruments
how do you pick and handle your suture
material
different knot tying techniques
incision and suture techniques and these
are seem very very basic but what we
found is we started doing hands-on
workshops here at wake forest
that people who have been doing surgery
for 10 15 even 20 years who consider
themselves as experts very often
handle the instruments the wrong way
they don't tie the knots appropriately
and again the reason for that is because
very often they have learned from
reading
papers or they have learned for example
from another scientist or another
student
so something very basic
as you can see here
they're talking about for example
a looped
or eyed needle
so this needle when you're going to pull
it through the suture because it's
thicker is going to actually then the
needle is going to end up
tearing
through the tissues
so the needles that you should use as
the one on the right here the non-eyed
needle but it's just shocking how many
times we still
see people using the eyed needles
and the reason is because they don't
they have never been taught they don't
know that
so you know how do we teach again we
talk about anonymous tools so here we
have my son he's learning how to do an
im injection um on what looks like a dog
a cat but it's actually a dog and again
obviously it's an alive animal
so here are some examples of what you
can utilize for teaching basic suturing
techniques
so one
on top here you can see you have a
straight line
and you also have these
marks where the suture should go
then we switch
to
the curved
incision and again you have the marks
and then we switch to something that has
the marks and then it does not and it's
really important that the sutures are
placed at the same distance from the
incision and in between the sutures and
then you step into actually closing an
incision site
so here are some examples of
very
various tools that we utilize
so here's an example of we already
showed you that
here's a tying board and again i know
we're going to be working with smaller
suture when you work with mice and rats
but you have to see how these ties
supposed to go and lay down and this
allows you to do that and then on the
bottom here you have other uh
instruments or tools that you can
utilize uh so the one for example on the
right here you have different incisions
that you can learn how to how to close
but one of the challenges that we found
and none of that is very similar to the
mouse so the mouse tissues are very thin
especially the skin on even the
abdominal wall
so it's very challenging to
step it up from these basic tools to
kind of more advanced tools but even
though we're still learning a basic
procedure like making a an incision so
here this is a
mouse model where we teach how to
utilize and how to perform an abdominal
incision
so you have this cartridge
here on the animal
and when you flip this over as you can
see here you have the skin
you have the abdominal wall and you even
have the linear alba
so
that's what we're now currently are
starting to utilize for this basic
training of how to make an incision but
then also how to close that incision
but what's really important that we have
to remember is that each one of these
tools you have to be able to identify
points of failure
so there's a lot of homemade tools that
are out there and some of them are great
some of them are not
but what's really important each one of
them you have to be able to identify
points of failure
what do i mean by that so for example if
i'm making my skin incision here we want
to make sure that that incision
is very smooth it's not jagged
so if it's jagged again that's a point
of failure
um so that's something that has to be
identified with each tool that you end
up utilizing for training
so then we go to phase two which is
advanced so here again we're talking
about gastric bypass procedures
so for us this phase
is going to involve
end-to-end anesthetimosis and
end-to-side anastomosis which is part of
this gastric bypass
procedure so what do we utilize to train
on these procedures so here on the
bottom you have a a two layer
intestinal tract which is very similar
this is actually soft and
it really feels like gi tract intestinal
tissue
and but this is pretty big this is about
one centimeter in in diameter but again
practicing that
anastomosis on this
it allows you to see how the sutures are
placed how the tissues come together
and then you have also other tools like
here and again but these are more single
layered
tissues
and then you have smaller
tools that you can utilize so this is
about uh two or three millimeters
in diameter um and here again you can
just make and perform these anastomosis
and practice them
so that's how you put the phases one and
two together
so when we implemented this phase what
we also found is looking at the animals
that are required for training and
that's a question that comes up very
often and we very often don't have a
good answer for it um so in this case
what we found that with the conventional
or the traditional training
which you can see here
we ended up using about
three on average three 13.5 animals per
person but when we implemented the
inanimate training models it dropped off
to about five animals per person so
that's a pretty significant
drop
and when let's say look at when you're
training uh 50 students
you're going to end up with 13 animals
with the conventional training that's 60
650 animals when you change it to
the refined technique the inanimate
models
that number drops to 250 animals which
ends up being 60 almost 62 percent less
animals used so again this goes along
with the three r's that we all talk
about
and it reduces the number of animals
that are utilized for training purposes
so from this portion the take-home
points are that
you end up increasing trainees
confidence and comfort when you utilize
these inanimate models before you step
into the live animals
and also allows us to use a
significantly lower number of animals
for training purposes
so
is there something that we have not
addressed yet so if you wouldn't mind
using the q a
questionnaire um to type in
is there something and again i kind of
gave the answer away uh when we talked
about that in the first slide we're
going to be talking about that in the
second half
so again it's not a trick question
that's right
so it's assessment
so why should we bother with assessment
so one of the things for us to remember
is that surgery
introduces trauma and trauma introduces
variables confounding factors into our
studies which we obviously want to limit
or eliminate if we can
so
one of the things that with surgery
and again the more invasive the surgery
is
the more of these changes are going to
happen
so catecholamines cortisol glucose
cytokines increase so for example when
we
work with the
diabetic animals
and perform these gastric bypass
procedures the glucose levels are going
to be important to us that's something
that we monitor so if that is going to
be affected by our trauma that we
introduce we have to remember that so if
we can perform the procedure
more precisely and more carefully
and not induce additional inflammation
that's going to
decrease
that variable that would increase the
glucose for example or decrease the
glucose
but again being able to perform these
procedures correctly you have to know
the basics understand the basics
then we also have you know the effects
gi motility immune function
oxygen demand pulmonary workload renal
workload
and a lot of these factors that you see
here
they actually last for
about nine days it takes about nine days
for these to normalize
um and so something to remember because
if you're collecting your
data your blood or whatever it is um
within that period
your surgery alone is gonna have an
effect it's gonna be a confining factor
here
so performing assessment
allows us to identify weaknesses
as well as strengths
of the surgeon the person that's
performing those procedures
and allow us to
then again improve on these weaknesses
when you improve on those allows us to
perform correctly the procedure that
we're doing
which also leads to standardization
across the board so allows us to compare
our data from study to study or from
different investigators
and then also allows us to reproduce
this information which is again
very very
and
important
know that some of the procedures you
can't standardize because if you're
looking for something different even
with the gastric bypass procedures i
think there's 12 or 13 uh
different types of everyone calls the
gastric bypass but there's some minor
differences there
but for example a procedure like a
subcutaneous pump implantation that
procedure can be standardized and it
should be standardized
and one of the reasons for that is that
within last few years we have seen
enormous amount of papers coming out and
suggesting the animal studies are poor
predictors
what happens then in clinics
and some of the things that have been
identified why that happens is because
experiments are poorly designed
the studies are poorly conducted
and they're poorly analyzed
so
if we actually
perform
the procedures appropriately the studies
are designed correctly and analyzed
correctly they can actually be a right
predictors of what happens
in
in clinics
so then here we also have
what we're going to be addressing is
the poorly conducted part so we're going
to talk about training again competency
assessment proficiency assessment
continuing education and that's how we
can actually improve and make sure
that these are
performed correctly
so the current practice practices
assessment of surgeons is
utilizing clinical outcomes so we look
at mortality and morbidity
and
obviously these observations are very
subjective
and it also doesn't allow us to identify
the weaknesses and the strengths and so
for example whenever something happens
after surgery it's always the surgeon
that's blamed for that
for that outcome but very often it could
be maybe we did provide the appropriate
uh perioperative care to that animal we
didn't have the appropriate temperature
for that animal
so if we can assess appropriately and
objectively the surgeon we can identify
where that mistake
came
so this type of assessment that we do
now in a lot of cases it's just reactive
so even just the
post approval monitoring um so
we when we do that it doesn't allow us
to identify the weaknesses and the
strengths
so you want to get away from the
reactive assessment and do proactive
assessments
so then of course the question comes out
what is
the appropriate assessment so which
assessment to use and there is
enormous amount of assessments out there
but we want to use something that's
obviously validated
and it can be repeated and that it works
but before we do that i want to go
through some of the definitions
so we kind of all are on the same page
so
how do we define competency
so it's abilities required to perform
surgical procedures to acceptable
surgical standards
then how would you define assessment and
i'll give you a couple 10-15 seconds to
think about it before we move to the
next slide so just think how would you
define assessment
so it's a summative process that
collects evidence about the trainee's
progress
towards a defined goal and involves
making judgment whether this goal has
been achieved
which obviously that fits quite well
so then we also have competency and
proficiency and these two terms very
often i utilize interchangeably but
they're not they're very very different
and i think also in our field we're
starting to pay attention a little bit
more to those as well but competency is
really what a surgeon can do and what
surgeon has been taught to do where
proficiency is what a surgeon actually
does during
a procedure
and they can be obviously influenced by
technical and non-technical and
behavioral abilities so an example is
that for example someone comes to a
surgical training
they're being assessed during it and
they're
said they're good they're competent
there but now when they go into their
lab and they work for a week or two
weeks
and they have 50 or 60 animals they have
to go through but they're still going to
be utilizing all the skills what they
have which they have learned during the
training and during the competency
assessment
and also for example if someone has a
death in the family
when they perform surgical procedure the
next day
is it going to have an impact on on them
and and it does it has been shown a
human surgery and that there are
actually hospitals that have um
regulations that will not allow
surgeons perform surgery for example
right after a death that happened in the
family but also even things like someone
who has a cold
you know they're tired
there are also impacts on their
technique so those are the things that
are going to
affect your proficiency
so again going back to which assessment
works
and during this period you know for the
last six or seven years when we have
been looking at these different
assessment tools
it's pretty frightening that even on the
human surgery side it's really not until
night late 1980s
when the laparoscopic
surgical techniques were introduced
where objective
assessment actually
started to develop
and currently really the laparoscopic
surgery is the only one that has
validated um
competency assessment tools that work
well and are utilized pretty much across
the board
in united states and also in europe
so for us to identify that we wanted to
also
do a small study where the objective of
that study was to determine the
feasibility
validity and reliability of evaluation
tools for competency assessment
of the gastric bypass surgery and mice
with the idea that you could utilize the
same tools for other surgical
assessments
hypothesis was that utilizing objective
assessment tools
will improve surgical performance
faster in comparison to clinical
assessment
or the traditional assessment that we
talked about
so we had 36 participants with no
surgical experience
the procedures that they were taught
with intestinal anastomosis you had side
to side anastomosis and side to end
anastomosis
so the way this process works is that we
did assessments before
basic procedures like resuture
techniques and etc
and then
we perform the training then assess
again
perform a training and assess and move
forward so again at each assessment with
the validated tools with the tools that
i'll show you you can actually identify
the weaknesses and the strengths so you
can concentrate on improving those
weaknesses with the clinical or
observatory assessment that becomes very
challenging to identify specific things
that you should improve
upon so
we use the clinical assessment for 18
participants and then what we also
utilize is the objective
structure assessment of technical skills
and this is assessment that
has been used in a lot of different
fields uh very commonly is used in
nursing
and has been validated there for various
clinical procedures and also
in surgery called surgical setting as
well
so we collected video of folks
performing these procedures and then we
had two blinded
micro surgical experts that performed
assessments
so
these are the tools that we have again
translated from the human surgery side
to the lab animal slash veterinary side
so on
the left hand side you have the
different
portions of the technique where you can
identify points of failure
and then on
the right hand side
you have column
one
which is when you do it very poorly but
we also describe that when you're doing
very poorly and then you have the column
on the right
which
describes
the procedure being done appropriately
correctly
and then you also in between you have
two and four which are not described and
again it's very challenging to get
five or six people to agree on one of
these descriptive term terms here or
these paragraphs so we leave a space in
between these
that something maybe falls between one
and three
and again so are these ideal perfect
tools for assessment no they're not this
is something that's a live document that
we actually improve
and adapt over time to the different
procedures that we utilize but it's
significantly better than just someone
watching doing clinical assessments for
mortality morbidity or just someone
observing a technique without
having any of these documents
and one of the challenges also
with this
as with assessments is that with this
technique there's really no argument
it's either you have
uh perform what it says here or you did
not
so
where someone is performing the
assessment of the trainee if the
assessor has a bad day they could also
score that person poorly and again that
has been shown on human surgery side
that it does happen or if there's
conflict you know people don't like each
other or you know they argue over
something again you could have within
with the subjective assessments you can
have a lot of uh
gray area there where with this
assessment that doesn't exist you get
away from that
so here also you know we're looking at
things like uh
skin incision
they have here
abdominal incis abdominal wall incision
and again they're described in detail
here
also looking at things like
retractor placement
retraction of the gastrointestinal
contents so
this assessment is like a cookbook for
this procedure so the advantage again
it's very objective
and identifies the weaknesses and the
strengths of that person and then it
also allows the person
practice
and improve on those weaknesses but also
what it does it allows the person to
walk away from training
and
practice on their own because now they
can go through all of these different
steps are defined here
and move forward
with with becoming competent or
improving with the procedure
the other advantage of this type of
assessments is that the icooks love
these
you know you can just demonstrate this
is where i am with my procedure
this is where we have been so if there's
any complications in the procedures with
the animals you can then identify if the
surgeon is competent
it's not the actual procedure but
something around that procedure
so
with this study
it was pretty clear that
incorporating the osats
allowed the students to obtain a higher
assessment score versus when you obtain
the clinical
performing the clinical assessments
and those students also
with the osat assessment
improve
significantly faster again that's the
point
of this
of this study
so in summary here we have demonstrated
that the osats
is a significantly better assessment
than a clinical assessment and osits is
also an effective teaching tool
effective competency assessment tool for
basic as well as advanced techniques
and it's an effective proficiency
assessment tool as well
and i know that i have not shown you
data for this but this is something that
we have also done
and this tool
does work quite well
so also when you talk about assessments
there's different things we need to
try to incorporate to make things easier
so with the previously
that
procedures were recorded
but here one of the things that we're
trying currently is the google glass so
if you're not familiar with google glass
um it's
something that you wear just like
glasses and on the side here it
it has a camera right here so you can
very easily record and then you can
provide feedback or the student can
visualize also how they're doing
and improve on their technique as well
so again
to me
it's really
challenging
and shocking
that we do provide
all of this training for
biomethodologies but when it comes to
surgical training we do not so obviously
the question comes up why is that
um
why aren't we doing that
and i think we know the answers to that
one it's money it's expensive to have
these tools
and
also the personnel having personnel that
is experienced in various surgical
procedures and rodents there's not going
to be one person that knows all of the
procedures that are being performed
so it's really challenging to identify
folks who have the surgical background
and have been taught and know how to
perform these procedures correctly and
then all of that includes time the
gastric bypass procedure you can't learn
that within a week even within a
two-week span it becomes challenging for
folks to become competent in that
procedure but we all want to squeeze
that into you know learning in one day
or two days it's just does it really
does not work
and also when we're looking at with the
presentations they were here earlier
today
you know with this with the new guide uh
the european uh regulations they have
now been implemented
none of those
re
guide guidelines and also even the law
here animal welfare
law in the united states they do not
allow us to justify for persona not to
be well trained because of finances
or lack of time
so
if we want to get away from
all of these publications are coming out
that animal studies are predictors we
really have to improve the way the
techniques are done
and maybe that not every phd student is
going to be able to do these procedures
you know either you can outsource
there's a lot of
organizations companies that provide
surgical models um and they have the
experience
in those models someone performing a
procedure you know for two weeks then
doing the studies for a year and then
performing again in two weeks just does
not work so unless we can implement
those things
i think that we're still going to
continue to see these type of
publications
and we also have to remember that
performing animal research is a is
really a privilege
and
we really have to try to fix things
internally
so make these refinements implement this
training
because if we don't it's going to
be
pushed upon us externally from
organizations that are not going to
provide us with as much freedom as we
have right now
and that's going to be really really
challenging that potentially we could
lose
the capability of performing animal
research or being significant or
restricted here in united states um as
you know the presentations they were
presented early this morning we know
that in uk there's significantly more
restrictions there as also in in europe
and in european union
so again if we want to change that we
should try to do that internally before
it's being forced upon us from external
forces
and this is something that um i wish i
remember who said this but it is easier
to defend an idea
than it is to implement it and this is
certainly true with training we all talk
about training every conference that we
go to it talks about training and now it
also talks about competency assessment
but we really have to start implementing
it
and you know simple things like
the the grants that we receive from the
from nih
none of those grants applications
actually talk about having money for
training um there's some for conferences
for example going i think it's like a
thousand dollar 15 1500 something like
that it's very limited um so we really
have to change our whole field
and how we think about training and how
we can incorporate the training
so
the main message from this presentation
i hope uh that was able to convince you
is that having appropriate training and
assessment
allows us to perform procedures
correctly which allows us to standardize
and reproduce our research which in the
end is going to increase
the ability to translate studies from
pre-clinical studies to clinics and
overall it's also going to improve the
animal welfare
and follow with the three r's of
reducing the animals use um
as well again
improving the animal welfare
so at this point
i just again one would like to thank you
for attending this
presentation and i'll be more than happy
to take i think we have some time
to take questions um if there are any
so one of the questions um what tools
actually make sure i have all of them
what tools do you use
for your phase 2 training with
non-animal models and more complic
complicated types of surgery
there really doesn't seem to be great
models for certain types of surgeries
sister
magnet cannulations microdialysis also
do you have trainees practice and
euthanize animals which have been
euthanized for another reason other than
training before moving on to live
animals
so the first part it's definitely true
we do not have a lot of good models
that are
available to us for these more
complicated procedures
but i think starting with the basics
is a good idea but then also that's why
one of the reasons why we
try to develop the model that i just
showed you here and the capabilities to
develop these models is there um i mean
so for example that
organization we work here at wake forest
they have a human model um that pretty
much you know when you make an incision
the skin bleeds um the muscles tear and
if you
introduce some kind of drug into that
person the heart rate goes up for the
respiratory you know all those different
things it's feasible it's there
but we're not willing to pay for that
that's one of the huge challenges that
we have to rethink and we have to
provide funding
for this type of training and these
models are
it's feasible to develop these models
but we need to provide the finances to
be able to purchase and utilize those
models
but in the meantime we can use some of
the models from the human surgery side
and incorporate them into
into the into the lab animal side and
there's various catheterization models
that we utilize for example uh for uh
from the human surgery side
and i can also
send you some more information about
this as well as regard to euthanized
animals we definitely do utilize those
implement them
and that's when we talk about utilizing
animals for training
and that
portions of that
um i guess when i talk about animals
talk about euthanized as well as
recoverable animals
and it's something that's useful
uh but it's also
the tissues feel very differently
obviously the tissues don't bleed so
that's a significant challenge but it's
also for some of the procedures it's a
it's a good step forward for the
gastrointestinal anastomosis for example
i don't think it is the tissues
deteriorate very quickly so they handle
very very differently
than live tissues so for the gastric
bypass procedures we have for training
we actually move from inanimate models
straight to
live animals
so next question how do you assess
proficiency
with specific procedure if you don't
have access to experienced people to
assess
the trainee's ability
i mean that's an excellent question
and this is where again
for us we have developed various tools
various assessment forms for all of the
procedures that we teach
and they're very similar so we have
two
assessment tools we have a global tool
and again this is translated from the
human surgery side that sense is kind of
the general uh skills that you would go
from procedure to procedure like for
example making knots or suture patterns
and then we have the specific
assessment tools for each procedure
describe step by step and the way i
showed you that example there
but again
if you don't have the person you can't
assess that person correctly
so it's for a lot of institutions i know
that's a huge huge challenge uh because
for example if there's someone you know
wants to do a gastric bypass procedure
and there's no one at that institution
that has done that um or has the
background in that you're not going to
be able to assess those folks
so
that's something that again if we ended
up
as a laboratory animal community pulling
a consortium
that
would develop
these type of tools together um then we
would be able to share them through our
community and really allow us to
improve the way we do research
but at this point that is challenging
but if you don't have someone with that
background
i mean unfortunately you can't do that
type of assessment
so i'm looking for this i don't see any
other
questions and make sure i miss anybody
so again i would like to thank you for
attending
uh this presentation and also i want to
mention um that if you could go and
visit the vendor hall
because again this conference would not
be feasible without the sponsors
so we would really appreciate if you
could do that
oh and there's a couple more questions
just came in um so one i am interested
in your thoughts on performing
assessments during surgery on approved
research protocols
obviously this has complications for
introducing variability to research
related to surgical proficiency but
reduces animal use for training
just make sure i understand the question
i'm interested in your thoughts on
performing assessments during surgery
so
obviously there are some like i believe
in uk
you can't use animals for training the
animals that you perform surgical
procedures on are already on the studies
and that's a significant challenge i
don't think you can really
do that so give an example you know if
you were going into a hospital for a
gastric bypass
and your options were
in resident who has never performed this
procedure is going to perform a
procedure while someone is assessing
them on it or you get an expert
performing a procedure obviously at
least i hope most of you guys if not
everybody would pick the expert surgeon
so again the person being there if
they're not trained doing those
assessments um in that type of
um
in that in their day in the
studies
to uh to me it doesn't really make sense
because you're going to introduce a lot
of different variables in there and i
understand the whole idea of looking at
the number of animals that you utilize
but i think it's been well demonstrated
even with their studies that you have
shown that the poorly done studies
really do not lead to good results or
translation into clinics and we have
spent enormous amount of money and
enormous amount of animals that we have
used
during those times so again
if we can utilize
the animals initially for training and
assessment
overall it's going to significantly
decrease the animals that number of
animals that we utilize
because again you decrease the variables
you decrease the number of animals that
you need for study to get the right data
and statistics
so where do you get the inanimate models
and so there's different
companies that provide them and i can uh
provide that information
uh to the folks that are attending this
specific presentation we can email them
to you after the conference uh but the
mouse model that i demonstrated that's
something that
um
we have to develop internally because
there's just nothing
like that out there
so i don't see any more questions so
again thank you so much and i hope you
guys are enjoying the conference um and
enjoy the rest of the day with the
presentations and also i hope you come
back next tomorrow uh for a whole bunch
of of really cool and worthwhile
presentations thank you so much